Now that we have our UI set up we need to start doing a little testing to make sure that everything is going to work
so the first thing what we're gonna do is we're gonna pull in our
Little pickup object and then we're gonna set its score and its time
So that when we run our project we have a score and a time
Set up and working. So let's go ahead and pop over to the engine now
All right, and now I have one already setting here
But if I don't have that we're gonna hit ctrl space and then what we want is we're gonna come up to our content
I'm gonna grab our pickup and we're just gonna drop that in here now inside the details panel again
I should have a score and a time. So maybe the score is a hundred and the time is ten
I'm just gonna bring this up a little bit. So let's go ahead and hit play
So there's our score and our time and there we go. And it says timer. So maybe I should make that say time
so we'll just do this really quickly if I come over here to my
Or there we go that one right there get text zero we need to
Let's go over to the graph
time
There we go. And then let's just compile and save that
And we're gonna close this and then there we go. That looks a little bit better
So, alright that is working how we wanted it. That's looking really really good
Alright, so with our testing now completed and our next part
We're going to be taking a look at creating
UMG menu so that we can have a game over menu and some other menus so that we can make a full game loop with
this project